on this episode I have two iconic guests
and I throw a right hook for a book
that's not my own you ask questions and
I answer them
this is the askgaryvee show
[Music]
everybody is gary vay-ner-chuk and this
is episode 89 of the askgaryvee show as
you can tell this is only the second
this is the second time Casey right only
the second time we've ever had that
guest and we've doubled it up and so I'm
really excited as many of you know who
watch the show
Jack Suzy and I did a great talk at
South by Southwest I've really gotten to
spend some nice time with them over the
last couple of months obviously have
known about them known them a little bit
and got to know them more and more and
so this is super fun for me for you guys
to be on the show I appreciate it
well why'd you tell the vaynernation how
you've been what do you guys up to who
you are for the one or two people that
don't know let's let's do that well
we're here because we love you so much
Gary but we're here because we got a new
book apps called the real life MBA we're
going around talking to people about the
ideas in it it's an MBA in a book all
right you know as way background you
know jack has got a long history and in
business and his writing partner in at
or a partner I've done a lot business
myself yeah and I've been building a
school in the last few years so Jack
Roush management's - we are granting
MBAs and we're growing at 40% a year
we're up to 900 students 38 years old
average age and it's so much fun to see
them progress through their companies
sixty-five percent of graduates have
gotten promotions while they were there
eighteen percent is the average rate of
the students in school while they're
there so it's been a great benefit and
tell them about your back career and I
mean you're you're you're semi-pro
hockey career that was a very weak well
I was sad when I was in high school I
captained everything won all these
awards and I went to college and played
against Canadians
I quickly really realized what I've
started let's get into the show we got
some questions let's do it Youssef wants
to know how important is failure you
hear a bunch of people saying how
important it is to fail but is it really
you have a great question you know look
I think failure has to be quantified if
fail that you've never can get up from
it again you know that's not a good
failure I think I think failure and
adversity are the two things I think
about for me that's an entrepreneur and
very entrepreneurial and always in my
own stuff
all the failures along the way even
going back to like the baseball card
show when I was 13 that I paid $400 for
a table and nobody showed up to that
baseball card show that was a learning
lesson those micro failures were super
super important I think you know it
depends on your stomach right like if
you if you really feel like go out of
business
I think people take one of two ways
right they're like just finished and
they're never able to get off the mat
and they go in a different direction so
to me I think quantifying the failure
support to me
Jack Suzy well I'll give you one I I
blow up a factory the second year I was
in business sky-eye my boss all of a
sudden didn't know me I went down to see
his boss in New York which he pointed me
to and the guy asked me a thousand
questions just use the Socratic method
and instead of me getting fired which I
thought was a high probability I learned
something from it so in every one of
these events you got to get yourself
back in the horse and how are you get
back on the horse and I want you ride
have to get knocked on your butt it's a
very big deal we tell our kids fail
early and often fail because then what
happens is when you do fail you know it
doesn't kill you you go on living and
you was okay you know I can pick myself
up here's how I'm gonna reinvent myself
here's how I'm gonna talk about it and
own it I would say look I got fired from
the Harvard Business Review I tell
people I was fired from the Harvard
Business Review and and here's the thing
it gives you heart for people who have
also fallen down and and you actually
sort of have everything but they totally
different understand if you look pull it
down you've been there and you can you
it just makes you a better person you
don't want to keep failing constantly
but to be scared better third though you
know you don't want to feel a little
tough but you but you can't be too
scared of it because I stopped you from
doing big things yeah you know it's
funny I was just having a meeting with a
lot of senior executives here at
vaynermedia and I said look guys I don't
need peacetime generals right
I need wartime generals meaning I need
executives like of course I know
this brands going well in this cool
brands going well misprints going well
what are you doing about the client
that's not happy right now
right and I think failure makes people
better at that and so that's another
kind of thing that I look for in this
subject matter
all right listen one Chris asks is
terminating the bottom 10% still a good
idea even on a team of all-stars someone
has to be last why don't you set this up
because obviously what wasn't the other
person Chris Chris knows about your
thesis on this is a very legendary POV
in corporate America entrepreneur land
like this is one of the iconic things
you put into the business world really
quick faster than normal
tell everybody what that is so everybody
knows and then answer the current
version actually when did you come out
with that give it a little life and then
tell me what the 25th of it mark if you
believe that the best team wins and that
business is a game you've got to feel
the best plans so in order to feel the
best players you look at any one point
in time who are your top 20
who are your middle somebody who you
bought bottom ten and you want to take
that top 20 and you want to make you
feel six foot four and maybe full power
what if they're six five to begin with
go to 16 what what you want to do though
desperately just make them know them
they're that good you want to be excited
you want turned on you want a passion
the middle 70 you want to describe these
Univ n top 20 and the bottom 10 you tell
them what's wrong with them what they're
not doing right you give them a chance
if they don't make it you let them go
but when you let them go you love them
as much on the way out as you loved him
on the way in I'm a big believer and
that's a big important thing migrate do
you feel that now you played at a G how
many how many employees under your wing
on average one for four hundred thousand
four hundred thousand employees that you
are in charge of during that run and as
a CEO G do you think that thesis holds
true to vaynermedia five hundred people
more important if you read I'm gonna go
a little quicker
how about ten there's a lot of five
people teams here v 7p
watching them listening every other and
it makes it hard for some because you're
looking straight at the five people Oh
got you started yeah and it's so tough I
was talking to somebody last night
at a conference who said he haven't let
go his former junior partner and I was
killing him but he had to do it she
wasn't delivering and I said look as
long as you take care of her and you're
fair and you have explained to her for
the last year what she wasn't doing
right you gotta do it do you think it
gets me about this question is the thing
we hear again and again we hear and this
question is even if everybody even if
it's an all-star team okay and there's
no such thing you got a look at your
team and say who is the weakest player
can I upgrade can I upgrade it's never
existing it's very very I mean you can't
fall in love with your team and say now
I have the perfect team but the next
manager comes in and says what was that
person thinking I mean I have another
take take on this - why do we always
focus on the bottom tenderness 27
minutes what what why are we saying how
exciting the top 25% why are we talking
about the winners because it's
rubbernecking
yeah it looks move on Jeremy asks as
businesses grow what is the best
solution for documenting policy
procedure and process so all are on the
same page Jeremy I hate this question
for a couple reasons
I you know it's interesting I'm gonna
piggyback off the last statement here
which is to me this is a defense
question right this is a bottom 10%
question I there is no business on earth
that one because they had a tight hand
book situation right so for me I mean
unless you're talking about liabilities
on a legal level you know GE should
worry about that to some degree because
of the level of lawsuits and by the way
they have 400,000 employees and there's
probably eight thousand lawyers or
there's people to do but a company of
500 people in the u they're not gonna
hear this under but you prepped it I'm
like how we have a handbook here and
nobody really knows about it I mean I
mean this is a 500-person it's still a
baby like that is something that I think
you need to be
worrying about at your [ __ ] yeah it's
forget documentation have a culture oh
you care have the culture been difficult
as soon as you're documenting things
you're wasting everyone's time it
becomes a bureaucracy all the matters of
your values of your culture make sure
they're being lived and you don't
document anything but everybody has to
know where you're going why you going
there and how you're gonna get it that's
leadership
right abso and that is the job that's my
job
it's yours of the people that work to
you and cascading down but everybody's
gonna know the mission they got to know
how they're gonna deal with behaviors
and then they've got a baby and one of
the consequences of getting that there's
another thing that I think people need
to understand this and by the way this
is gonna get very vain Erised
and India you'll enjoy this and
everybody here as I started bringing in
more senior people they wanted to bring
in more of these things and I made them
understand I'm like look you understand
we're still this entrepreneurial engine
and if somebody comes into this company
and they're so worried about the
handbook and so worried about reviews
and so worried about all these things I
don't want them here now not that
they're bad but they're not the right
players at this time I was the best
player on my fourth-grade baseball team
there's not a single baseball team in
America and major league baseball that
needs me on their team and so I was the
right player for that time but then has
everybody got much bigger than me I
became not so much and so we now need
different people that maybe care about
some of those things as we continue to
grow but not at that time so the other
thing here is the right employee at the
right time at the right age of the
company no no she she know what's so
funny back to what we talked about
she wasn't gay boss to me she's like oh
crap cool I have a new article Jared
wants to know what's the best way to
scale a business with an inherently low
profit margin so Jared's got a low
profit margin issue he's asking the best
way to scale it jack says new products
new innovation new angle if you've got
the last thing you want to be thinking
about is making the lodge
something with small margins you would
you want to find ways to take the assets
you have a transformer into a
high-growth exciting player in maybe
adjacent fields but take the assets you
have and deploy them to grow the
business but not maybe the existing
business completely just get away to
have the little marketing businesses
create services right I mean that what
you did Jeannie you took all the stuff
that was low margin and you added on
high margin services you don't want to
be in a little margin business you got
to do everything with your innovation
and creativity to get away from it I'm
gonna go with an interesting different
angle from an own life experience when I
got into my dad's business into three
million dollars in revenue and ran on
the 10% gross profit before expenses it
was a family business right it was all
right that was that's low margin the
liquor business is bad because there's a
middle wholesale part that takes 25% of
the 50% that a retailer normally takes
extremely low margin what I did was
actually went the other way meaning I
took the low margin items that were
driving the stores business and I
actually bet on them what I did was I
took all the items like Santa Margherita
and Kendall Jackson the liquor items
that were low margin at cost by the way
and I used them to market to drive
people into the store as the honey and
then I merchandised the store and built
the brand that they came in for Kendall
Jackson but I sold them a different
Chardonnay margin and so both these
things are of course right I'm curious
and we don't know where you are in your
life cycle what I've watched a lot of
people do is try to go look you know
band-aid off from low margin to some new
innovation that maybe the market doesn't
want
I think the hedge there that's
interesting to understand I really felt
the effects of this was go is use it as
an offense right now we're testing
Facebook Ads for my wine business and
everything we're using are these low
margin items because they have the brand
equity to drive in and then we'll take
care of it from there so you may be far
enough along in your business where of
the first answers here were 107 right
you need to get into a place where the
margins are gonna get right but I worry
depending on your sophistication as an
operator that you go complete cold
turkey there's a way to use the low
margin items as an
that's a burger but but I would use the
low bottom said the margin from those
low margin items to invest in other
areas 100% that's what I did right you
do we the pennies we made turning the
advertise drove people in then I grabbed
them and so they did it it up India West
Coast beer geek wants to know how can
efficiency and creativity better work
together they will be inefficient into
the time and space you give them to be
honest I mean I was I mean I was a
creative long time and then I became the
boss of the creatives and I knew how
much fat was built into their writer's
block and their you know thinking and
everything in the sudden they needed and
I had to come out of the gentleman
surrounds where you had to turn out
seven eight stories a day I knew that
the creativity expanded into that space
and of course you gotta be creative be
creative need sort of time to decompress
and so forth but I would give them a
little bit too much or maybe not we in
general but it is easy to listen to them
moan and groan about meeting more so
creatives can be efficient to get
efficiency you gotta be creative and you
get a creative people and an efficiency
that doesn't beat some woman in a hole
driving every day these people not
thinking of new ways to do things coming
up with incremental improvements making
things better every day finding a better
way every day takes a thinking headset
and you want that mentality in your
company you want the whole company to be
thinking about every day what is a
better way of doing what I'm doing now
yeah I'm a big fan of betting on your
strengths and and also really
recognizing putting players in the best
position to succeed and we have nothing
but creatives here of the 500 plays 200
of them and if I deemed if we've deemed
if Tina who runs our credit department
deems that this person is bringing us
quality I think one thing that a lot of
people try to do is mold them into being
more efficient I've done that plenty of
times in my career one of things I've
decided now is to look at it more as a
net-net game right you know I may not
like that they need to be in a Zen
with unicorns in it I may not but if I'm
okay with the output right if I'm okay
net that 365 day here I'll put I'll take
it right you could have the most prima
donna creative but if they do that one
thing that you decide drives the ROI on
the flip side you could have somebody
who's the most efficient but lacks the
magic what you have to really do is its
wide receivers in football listen
they're at the mercy of the quarterback
getting the ball that's why they don't
get to touch the ball the quarterback
touches the ball the running back
touches the ball when it's the calls
played the receivers don't so many
variables and it's I'm very intrigued by
that psychology that being said you know
I value speed and execution over
everything and so I definitely sit on
that Mendoza line if there's a coin toss
if I'm even debating it if I'm even
debating your value as a creative over
the efficiency in the output you're in
trouble that sensational one of the
famous nobody exactly but one of the
things that really can kill a company is
the innovators sit over here in a box
and they're Thomas Edison and they're
Steve Jobs it's just any of these people
and then everybody else keep your head
down and be a grunt yeah you lose the
minds of these people on tripperz you
want everybody to be an innovator
all right 100% and and it's interesting
here at Vayner we're a classic agency we
want more practicality from our
creatives and we want our account
strategist being creative and I've been
a big benefit for us and you know what
else it does it creates mutual respect
because when the innovators are over
here they sit on a higher ground now and
it deflates the momentum and the a great
vengeance right anytime you get prima
donnas in an organization and race
everyone around so so let's wrap up with
this we don't do a wrap-up session we're
gonna make an unique thing why this book
and more importantly you have such a mix
of people that listen and watch to my
show right you've got a ton of people in
start-up entrepreneurial corner you know
obviously cuz the agency there's a
plenty amount of executives in Fortune
500's bloggers media types when you look
at this book and and you guys put
yourself awareness against this book who
benefits the most of course as like
wanting the book to be successful we
want everybody and I'd like
would mean a lot to me to support these
guys I want you on it but going down the
pecking order who do you think or how do
the individual segments that could read
this book where do you see them
benefiting from what angles I mean what
we want to do is want to create an MBA
in a book because you can start off in
business and you can get very good at
one thing and then there's something in
your head that saves you I wish I had
the 360 mindset you know that's sort of
what an MBA I know I what it gives you a
sort of give you the CEOs mindset you
sort of see all all the different
functions working together and we looked
around and that book didn't exist it so
for people who didn't have an MBA who
just wanted one but didn't want to give
up two years of their life to go get one
of the good drilliam dollars right I
mean anybody who's managing anyone a
small team of five people or a team of
500 can use the tools that are in the
wild you name it management no no no
that's yeah well I know but that but
it's an interesting insight that that's
where you went first and I'm intrigued
by why he let go there first because he
believed in it so much that's what I'm
talking about managing small groups I
can't well and what we want to do is
create an atmosphere in the company it's
got some of the buzz you've got here
across every company so building a wild
team and having employees know how to
play in a wild team is a critical part
of this story please one last thing is
that there's a whole section of the book
on your career and it's about you know
what should I do with my life how do I
get out of a career stall and how do you
become an entrepreneur what does it
really take there's all look a lot of
the book is about winning strategically
smiting your competition building a
great team but look frankly people spend
a lot of brain time thinking about their
own careers and how they get to be where
we're where they're really fulfilled and
they're doing what they want to do so
the whole there's a chunk of the book
that do you believe on a real quick
question do you believe by the way you
guys look great in this photo do you how
many photos how many how long this photo
doesn't vary longer than me
not the her Oh
to get beyond that to look like that was
real work house imagine well do you
believe do you believe that a top 25 50
Business School MBA in April 2015 is as
valuable in the marketplace as it was 5
10 and 25 years ago go back to top gen
yeah ok yes yes absolutely
how about how about 11 to 20 that stops
the slide pretty quickly at the top job
the line is out the door with the kinsey
with the whoosh with everybody else
lined up when you get in so in a top 10
school you're making a huge 300 thousand
dollar Gusman but their return was
pretty good no high pays off pays off
what about if so many of those kids cuz
nice now I'm spending a lot of time with
those kids so many of those kids want to
become startup entrepreneurs do you
believe that the ROI is equally as good
at not $300,000 investment if they want
to go down that path versus going to
bein a McKinsey who start paying them
tremendously strong salaries and bonuses
that can drive down that dad's on the
cloud in their idea let's face it yeah
what's your intuition tell you I think
all we are running all the time either
people don't want to be quote
entrepreneurs it's not a profession it's
the output of a great idea yeah it's not
like being a lawyer or a doctor all
right what is your idea what is the
value proposition and can you win with
it so I always on this show where I ask
a question to my audience and they
answer in the comments I'm gonna allow
you guys one of you can take it both and
you can have a separate one what kind of
question do you want to ask that you
know by the way use this as market
research that's what I alright yeah I
know a question jack I look in the book
we make the case that the place you
should be working is what we call your
area of destiny that intersection of
what your real what you're uniquely good
at and what you love to do okay well
you're uniquely good at and what you
love to do that's this really rich
beautiful territory area of destiny and
I'd love to know how many people think
they're actually working in their area
of destiny I love it guys thank you so
much for being on the show yeah
I would get the book let's support these
guys d-roc let's link it up and I'll go
to charge yeah every all proceeds to
charity I think that was every nickel
well that probably changed the variable
of your success of being on this show so
good job guys when Excel you keep asking
questions we'll keep answering all the
info on this episode
[Music]
yeah
yeah
yeah
[Music]